alors je vais demander en régie pour
avoir confirmation que se passe-t-il
dans la suite du programme ah bah c'est
en mettant ça alors est-ce que vous
pouvez m'apporter mes fiches qui sont
juste en régie
alors on va retrouver tout de suite les
news c'est parti je suis arrivé mardi
entre dimanche et lundi voilà j'ai pris
vraiment des congés pour vivre les
concerts à fond le jour de congé ouais
il y a trois choses qui me feront
enfermer le commerce c'est problème de
santé la famille ou Mylène Farmer on est
tout un groupe de campeur qu'on est une
semaine voilà avec nos tantes et voilà
on se relait de temps en temps pour
l'attente pour faire l'ancienne on va
acheter des jardins des lingettes ce
genre de truc vous faites tous ces
concerts
pour la plupart neuf sur cette tournée
sur 13 ouais donc mon fond d'écran c'est
vous bah sonnerie de téléphone c'est le
générique des 12 Coups de Midi et j'ai
même mon cinquième j'ai fait un exposé
sur vous j'ai eu 17 sur 20 d'ailleurs
Merci à VOUS du coup
non mais c'est pas vrai si c'est vrai
j'y crois pas vous y croyez pas mais
c'est pas possible
ça vient de tomber
prends des jours de congés
pour ce petit connard vraiment votre vie
je la connais pas par cœur
merci je vous aime mais moi aussi je
vous aime on s'est privé de plein
d'autres concerts parce que c'était ce
cousin là vraiment le plus important et
la déception est immense et il faut
avouer que son public lui a bien vendu
en la couvrant de cadeaux qu'elle
n'oubliera jamais comme ce sachet de
cendres funéraire qu'un fan lui a lancé
sur scène
[Musique]
je suis super Richard le défenseur des
super riche mon super pouvoir c'est mes
petites placards qui me permettent de
résoudre les problèmes des personnes qui
ont les moyens de ces offrir
semble un peu stressé
à tout à l'heure merci
et je me suis dit bah pourquoi pas
représenter cette minorité des personnes
blanches de plus de 50 ans riches qui ne
sont jamais représentés c'était
important pour moi également
ça ressemble imaginez le poisson sushi
dans l'aquarium
d'accord et j'en avais plusieurs et du
coup je leur avais 4 comment il
s'appelait
total EDF
VDM pour rigoler non et le 4e
quand un enfant coréen naît il a un an
tout de suite chaque premier janvier
c'est son anniversaire c'est
l'anniversaire de tous les Coréens le
1er janvier il a un an de plus ce qui
donne des situations ubuesques comme
quand un enfant est né le 30 décembre il
a un an deux jours plus tard joyeux
anniversaire il a deux ans alors qu'il
est à peine de sortir de sa maman et ils
sont vivants encore bas non ils sont
morts
ah Total et EDF ont été électrocutés non
vous rigolez c'est une blague non non il
y a eu un
court-circuit et le filtre qui est relié
forcément à la prise électrique le fil
qui est dans l'aquarium ben ça fait et
les poissons ils sont tous morts comme
ça
l'anguille est un des rares poissons qui
survivait dans l'eau polluées de la
Tamise alors à l'époque des
rationnements cette gelée était un
incontournable
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui
difficile de vous mentir
[Musique]
c'est immonde et vraiment même pour mes
18 ans j'ai fait un discours et j'ai dit
j'ai hâte d'avoir 18 ans pas pour mon
père mais juste pour faire les douze
coups de midi pour vous voir je suis là
ça me fait vraiment plaisir
merci beaucoup je vous aime
pour mon entrée je suis habillé en vulve
parce que déjà je trouve les vulves sont
pas assez représentées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et Chris marquez j'ai dit
les villages people vous avez fait
savoir que
ça ne devait pas se faire que vous étiez
pas d'accord
et enfin le fait qu'il fasse venir
des imitateurs à gauche alors sur le
plan musical bon bah c'est pas grave qui
joue ma chanson mais mais ce qui
m'embêtait c'est que enfin en fait ça
nous a remis au numéro 2 d'etchat donc
finalement c'était pas si grave qu'ils
viennent là ça nous a fait de la pub la
difficulté de l'orthographe française
est un choix délibéré et politique en
1835 l'Académie française décide de
compliquer volontairement des mots en
ajoutant des doubles consonnes et en
rajoutant des lettres qui viennent du
grec et du latin n'oublions au passage
certaines origines allemandes de
certains mots non mais alors là
parce que tu es un égoïste voilà je
voulais te dire une entreprise en plus
[Applaudissements]
mais dans l'oreille il y a pas tellement
d'os ici
on est tous sortis de l'auberge
vous battez les jambes vous connaissez
même pas les autres
exemple avec le mot symphonie il s'écrit
toujours comme ceci en italien et en
espagnol en français il a pris un y un
pH et même un m au milieu histoire
d'être bien compliqué le but à l'époque
évidemment c'était de se démarquer avec
la montée des nationalismes au 19e
siècle la langue française devait être
différente elle devait se mériter et
inconsciemment quelque part c'est
peut-être encore le cas aujourd'hui
je suis si soulagée
de commencer à me sentir quand même un
peu seul
l'âme papa sans l'autre c'est comme une
paire de couilles c'est inséparable
c'était à bonne ambiance j'ai rencontré
plein de gens donc top donc vivement
l'année prochaine